- Good morning, I hope you're, oh,
it's a wet morning, it
just rained all night long.
Ah, but good morning, it's Mark Wiens,
I'm in Trat, Thailand and this is day five
of our eastern provinces of Thailand
food and travel tour.
Today we are gonna be in Trat, the town,
we're gonna be exploring the food and so
we're gonna go on a food
tour and I'm gonna share
all the food with you today.
(upbeat electronic music)
This is a great market, you'll find.
It's a really friendly
market, you'll find some very
unique ingredients that are
specific to this region,
to Trat.
There's lots of seafood,
there're some giant fish,
people are very friendly here.
It's not that busy, it
has a calm feel to it
- (speaking in foreign language)
- To be honest, the morning
market is a great place
to walk around and to get a feel for Trat
and the ingredients that are available.
But there's really not
much going on in terms
of pre-cooked food to eat.
So we've decided to go check out,
it's just down the road, a
place that's known for its
noodles and rice with
a variety of seafood.
The restaurant is located
just behind the market
but you now are starting
to get into the charming,
old wooden houses, the
heritage area of Trat.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- It's a classic, old-school
legendary restaurant
in Trat, and they have
both all sorts of different
types of noodles that you can order
as well as different toppings
on rice but specifically
seafood, especially crab and especially
(speaking in foreign language),
which is mantis prawns,
and so since I've already
actually in Chanthaburi,
I had a couple bowls
of mantis prawns with
noodles, I decided to try
a couple rice dishes here.
This is one of those
restaurants in Thailand that
is not only a restaurant,
but it's a museum
so if you& look around there
are photos of famous people
along the walls, it's completely
decked out in decoration.
And I ordered a couple of
different unique dishes.
The first dish that we have
to begin with is called
(speaking in foreign language)
And these are crab eggs,
so female crab eggs
stir-fried with chilies
and I think, garlic.
And there's some fish sauce
and chilies on the side,
but just look, look at that.
That looks potently delicious.
Mmm-hmm.
The crab eggs are like yolk, egg yolk,
but more, more starchy, more condensed.
That's definitely a unique
dish, and very tasty.
Another dish that I'm very
looking forward to trying.
This one is (speaking in
foreign language), with
(speaking in foreign language) and
(speaking in foreign language)
is stir-fried holy basil.
You can get your choice of meat.
This one, though, is with mantis prawn,
so you can see these are mantis prawns.
She added in garlic, she
added in some onions,
she added in banana peppers.
I've had (speaking in foreign language)
in almost every variation,
but this will be a first
for me with mantis prawns.
You've got those mantis prawns.
They're like crayfish,
they're similar to shrimp.
Then you've got that holy basil,
you've got the chilies in there.
Mmm, that salty, balance
of sweetness, and then just
that shrimpiness.
All right, that was pretty decently good.
Definitely some unique
versions of (speaking in foreign language)
but they also have a full noodle selection
with a mix of seafood that's worth a stop.
It's a pretty legendary
place to eat in Trat.
Now if you ask any local in Trat
which is one of the best places to eat
many will recommend this one
(speaking in foreign language)
restaurant which is rice
and curry, which is located
at a gas station, a petrol station.
(upbeat techno music)
This is the spot, it's located
behind the Shell gas station.
I didn't know this ever but
it's Khao Gaeng San Toong,
and San Toong is a small
town that we passed through
driving from Chanthaburi to Trat.
It's in Trat, but they're
known for their food.
It's like one of those
cities that everybody knows
has spicy curries.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- This is one of those
restaurants where it's
way too easy to get way
too excited and just
start pointing and choosing
and before you know it
you have a table full of food.
The portion sizes aren't huge,
so we can definitely handle this.
Wow, the food looks insanely delicious.
This is the type of food,
(speaking in foreign language)
which in Thai means rice and curry.
You'll find it all over
Thailand, it's one of
my favorite styles of eating.
They have all the dishes prepared.
Usually a bunch of different
curries, but all sorts of
variety of different dishes.
This one is some type of
bird, um, she called it
(speaking in foreign language)
or something like that, and
I think this is the bird one.
Yeah, you can see those
chili seeds in there.
Oh, that looks masterful.
Oh, what a dish!
Yeah, uh, that one has a
little bit of heat to it.
It's some type of bird that
you can eat all the bones,
so you can crunch right through the bones,
I mean, they do have
quite a crunch to them
and you better chew them well,
but you can eat all of the bones.
It's almost like, the meat
is almost like duck-tasting.
This one is (speaking in foreign language)
which is a sour curry, which
is made all over Thailand
but very different in
many different places.
This, there's fish in here,
and lots of pineapple.
It almost looks like a tomato
sauce but that's chili.
Mmm.
Some of the dishes can be
on the sweet side, in Trat,
generally speaking, but
what I love is sweet dishes.
Well, sweet and spicy dishes
that are sweetened with fruit,
like pineapple.
That gives it a, I mean that
fruity sweetness, the pineapple
comes in here so nicely, but
it's salty at the same time.
There's chilies in there
so it's a little spicy.
Moving right down the line,
I think this one is the
(speaking in foreign language)
which is a jungle pig, a wild boar,
fried with a similar curry
paste, all the seeds in there,
the Kaffir lime leaves.
Mmm-mmm.
Mmm.
Oh, what I can taste
that's different in that
is the black pepper.
Oh, there's a lot of black
pepper going on in there.
I just went up to the
front, I asked them what
the dishes are stir-fried.
They're all included with
the, most of the curry dishes,
and they said they're all
(speaking in foreign language)
which is the pineapple
crown, very common ingredient
that you will find throughout Trat.
It always goes with spicy curries,
and it goes so well
because it has this amazing
crunch that's similar to bamboo shoots.
But at the same time it has a little more
of an acidic flavor.
What an ingredient.
And that brings us
directly to our next dish,
which this is probably
my favorite dish of Trat.
(speaking in foreign language)
Which is a deer curry, again with
the pineapple shoots.
When you have that many
chili seeds per bite,
plus the pineapple crown, plus deer,
there's just no way it
cannot be a flavor explosion
in your mouth.
Whoa.
What a dish.
Oh, that's ultimate.
That's so unbelievably good.
It's spicy, it's balanced
in flavor, there's a little
bit of citrusy acidicness
in there, and that meat
is very, very tender.
That deer is, it's tender.
It's delicious, it's
absolutely sensational.
The final dish is the
(speaking foreign language)
and (speaking foreign language)
are the leaves.
This is a very popular dish
in this region of Thailand.
It's always a very sweet dish,
usually a little too sweet for me.
It's good, but it does have that real
sweet-and-sour flavor to it.
The pork is tender.
I do love the leaves, though.
It's like one of those
leaves that remains,
that holds its shape and remains crunchy
even if you cook it for a long time.
But yeah, for me it just
doesn't quite compare
to all the spicier curries.
Everything is good,
but definitely the deer
and the bird, those are
my two favorite dishes.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna double
back for some of that bird.
That's awesome.
And that crunch of the bones.
(upbeat techno music)
(sighs)
Oh, that was just one of
those utterly satisfying
meals in Thailand.
This is a gas station that
you're gonna wanna come to,
not to fill up your car,
but to fill up your stomach
and it, you're gonna experience
ultimate satisfaction.
That was so good, my
mouth is still tingling
from all those flavors and those chilies.
From here, we're gonna walk
around and just explore
a little bit of the downtown,
old town area of Trat.
And then later on this
evening for dinner we have
a big seafood feast coming up.
(upbeat techno music)
After that much good food,
I need to walk around a little bit.
I made it to Wat Phai Lom,
and this is the central
Buddhist temple of Trat town.
And you enter, there's quite a lot
of roosters running around.
It is quite a unique stupa structure
unlike anything I've seen in Thailand.
But I think the real beauty, I think
it's actually closed
right now, I can't get in,
but the real beauty around
here are the gardens.
If you're quiet you can
hear the birds chirping,
all sorts of different
birds, there are flowers.
Gotta move on to the
Trat history museum now.
(rooster crowing)
For sure, one of the
architectural masterpieces
and buildings of preservation is the Trat
history museum, and it's
housed in the old city hall.
It's a beautifully
restored wooden building.
Trat.
Half a hundred islands, precious rubies,
sweet zalaccas, high quality
ridgeback dogs, Koh Chang
naval battle, it's the very
eastern side of Thailand.
I was the only one at the museum,
and it's really nicely done, actually.
Really nice and quiet,
it walks you through
the history of Trat all the
way from the natural resources
to when the Chinese came and
when it was an important,
very important seaport and trade center.
And the building itself is a highlight.
It's worth checking out on its own.
Everything is located
pretty close within Trat,
but just down the road from the museum
is the (speaking foreign
language) community,
which is one of the old
canal-side communities.
I'm just gonna take a
little stroll through here
and see what we can find.
There are old houses, they're,
now they're lots of guest houses.
There're some cafes.
It's pretty, pretty peaceful area.
(upbeat techno music)
And within the community,
one of the things
I wanted to check out is
this walkway along the canal.
It's pretty cool, you can
walk along the waterway
and it gives you a different
perspective on the community.
You can see the houses, you
can see the jungle growth
and it's so unique and so peaceful.
(upbeat techno music)
It looks like it's gonna
rain this afternoon
so I'm gonna go back to the
hotel, stay for a few hours,
rest this afternoon and
rest for the seafood
dinner that's coming up.
There was a nice rainstorm this
afternoon and we had a nice
rest back at the hotel.
Now it's cleared up,
it's the late afternoon,
we're on our way to a seafood restaurant,
and it's about a 25 minute drive away.
(upbeat techno music)
That was about a 25
minute drive but it was
a gorgeous ride, it was, it's so lush here
and we followed the
signs towards Laem Sok,
but this is Laem Tieng
which is a cape south of
Trat town, and this looks like
a little fishing community.
The (speaking in foreign
language) who owns the restaurant,
he literally walked outta the
restaurant to come meet us
at our car and this is
gonna be outstanding.
This is the next level of laid-back
seafood family restaurant.
- (speaking in foreign language
- He has all of the seafood
live in swimming pool tanks.
He was showing us the
mantis shrimp, which are,
I mean they look like aliens.
They look like a combination
of a praying mantis
and a massive prawn, massive shrimp.
We're gonna have some alien
mantis shrimp tonight.
The main dining room section is upstairs
so you have a view of the ocean.
Wow, this is a, this is a
beautiful home seafood restaurant.
- (speaking in foreign language)
(laughing)
- So we told Uncle just to
hook us up with a set menu,
and so he is like, shopping
at an aquarium for us,
just with baskets gathering seafood.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Ying and I are not eating
this seafood feast alone.
We are hanging out with
- (speaking in foreign language)
- And they are from, as
you can see their t-shirts
(speaking in foreign language)
- Yeah!
- Which means like, what
to eat, the food in Trat.
And so they have a Facebook,
they blog about food
in Trat and so it's gonna be an honor
to hang out with them and eat
this seafood feast tonight.
We are getting special permission
from the chef and owner,
the (speaking foreign
language), the uncle himself
to come back in the kitchen.
I mean everything's incredibly fresh,
everything's gonna be awesome,
but those mantis alien shrimp.
Wow.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- They took all of that fresh
seafood, they put it into
a giant wok of bubbling water,
so that's the first step
is just boiling it,
especially the crab and the,
those things are huge!
- (speaking in foreign language)
- He's just trimmin' them
up right now, cutting the,
those are some really
really sharp tentacles
and claws that they have.
(sizzling oil)
The mantis shrimp go
straight into the hot oil
and they're gonna deep
fry and then they're gonna
combine it with garlic.
(upbeat techno music)
I think most of the dishes
are ready, I'm running back
up to the table, it's
time to start eating.
By the way, do not get too
excited and hit your head,
whoa, like that.
Do not hit your head, that
could hurt really bad.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Hey!
- Hey.
- (speaking in foreign language)
(laughter)
- It's almost time to eat
but he is actually cracking
the crab and preparing it for us.
Whoa, amazing service,
he's absolutely awesome.
This seafood looks, we
got like, the biggest
of all types of seafood
that I've ever seen.
Show us how to open (speaking
in foreign language).
- [Diner] Expert, expert.
- [Second Diner] Pick up.
- [Third Diner] (speaking
in foreign language)
- [Mark] Wow.
Wow.
I'm gonna grab one of these gigantic,
seriously extraterrestrial,
look at that amount of garlic on top, too.
The best. It is like armor.
It's like a shrimp but way harder.
It almost feels like plastic.
Oh, look at all that
flesh underneath there.
Oh, look at that.
(laughter)
That's like a muscle.
- Mmmm.
- Wow.
- Look at it.
- Oh, that's ridiculous.
- Oh, wow.
- Wow.
- Lucky man!
- The lucky one with all the eggs in it!
It's just insane, it's like
shrimp but it's more juicy,
more tender, more sweet.
It almost is, it almost tastes like crab.
A cross between shrimp and crab.
And you can also really taste
that garlic on there, too.
That is, that's absolute insanity.
(speaking in foreign language)
- No more talking.
(laughter)
Time to eat.
- [Mark] This is one
thing, once you pick it up
and start eating, you will not,
you will not set it back down.
That was one of the
greatest things I think
I've ever eaten in my entire life.
It's time to move on
to the gigantic shrimp.
And there should be
some tomalley in there.
Some, oh look at all those juices,
okay, we will save this head, oh man.
Look at that.
- Wow
- Wow.
- [Second Diner] That's good.
- If you were to spread this
out, it's curled right now,
it would definitely be as
long, as tall as my face.
(laughter)
And for this, we are all
gonna dip into that sauce.
(happy moaning)
- Very yummy.
- Crazy good.
It's so ridiculously
muscular and firm and sweet.
It's insane.
I'm gonna grab a little
bit a chili action,
I'm gonna put this right, right onto that.
Oh, that's gonna be the ultimate bite.
I've already taken one
bite, but you can like,
you can balance things on it, it's so big.
- [Diner] Wow.
(scattered applause)
- (mumbles)
Okay, we're moving in
for the crab, we're going
for those claws first.
Peeled perfectly, and the owner,
(speaking in foreign language),
he peeled them for us.
It doesn't get better if you get
giant crab that's peeled for you.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- Okay, okay.
So two bites, the first bite no sauce,
the second bite we'll dip.
Candy bar.
It's like a candy bar.
Next bite, seafood sauce.
There's nothing better you
could put in your mouth.
(laughter)
- [Diner] That's true.
- Next up are the (speaking
in foreign language)
which are the blood cockles,
and these are by far
the biggest blood cockles
I've ever seen in my life.
Mmm.
Oh, that's amazing too!
Oh, you can taste the salt water in them.
It almost has an oyster texture, but mmm.
Wow, those are succulent.
Crazy succulent.
Okay and you've gotta eat this with the
(speaking in foreign language) seafood.
Yeah, is definitely better
with the seafood sauce.
Um, I mean that kinda masks
like, the fishiness of it
and that just burns your lips going down.
- [Diner] (speaking in foreign language)
- Okay so it's called
(speaking in foreign language)
which is fried rice
with crab, and it's just
loaded with crab, you gotta
add some prik nam pla,
which is fish sauce and chilies to that.
It's absolutely insane.
That's like the type of fried
rice you could possibly eat.
It's loaded with crab.
It's like equal portions
of crab and rice in that.
Next up are that grouper,
that fresh grouper.
What he, they'd made two dishes out of it.
One is a soup that they
made with the head,
and then the other they
deep-fried the tail,
they deep fried and put on some kind of a
sweet chili sauce on it.
Check out the soup here,
let's try that fish,
that fish does not get
any fresher than that.
It's, it would be impossible.
Look at how that just flakes apart.
I think it's (speaking
in foreign language),
lots of lemongrass in
there, it's nice and sour.
That fish is unbelievably firm.
- [Diner] (speaking in foreign language)
- I think this is the final
dish, which is the fried
grouper with sauce, and there's
also some pickled shallots.
Oh, spectacular as well.
Mmm, there's shallots.
Mmm, the pickled shallots,
the fresh fish, it's crunchy.
Everything is insanely good.
(upbeat techno music)
For sure, one of the most
spectacular seafood meals
I've ever had in my life.
I'm on my way to go wash my hands
and you've gotta check out the sinks.
The sinks are on this balcony outside,
and it just kinda goes off the ledge here.
Oh, I think that's the kitchen down there.
And then, you've got a,
the soaps right here,
be careful not to knock
the soaps off the ledge,
which could very easily happen.
Or, oh there's a random crab claw squeezer
right there and a mallet.
(laughter)
You don't wanna bump that off the wall,
that's for sure.
Great handwashing facility.
Oh, I love it.
Perfect.
Can't even find my shoes, there's,
for one thing there's a
lot of people eating now,
but I am definitely under the influence of
that seafood.
It just looks like a blur of shoes to me.
It was an absolutely
spectacular seafood feast,
and there's nothing better
than eating with friends.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- (speaking in foreign language)
- And again, (speaking
in foreign language).
That's their Facebook
page, I'll have the links
in the description box.
Check them out, they're just cool,
they're fun to eat with.
- Yo, bye bye.
- Bye bye.
- Again I wanna say a huge thank you to
(speaking in foreign
language) and his friends
for joining us for
dinner and this is their
favorite seafood restaurant,
for them showing us this spot.
And again, they are from
(speaking in foreign language).
I'll leave their links in
the description box below.
But this is such an unassuming restaurant,
I mean it looks like a
shed from the outside,
the (speaking in foreign
language), the uncle here,
he is an amazing man, he
serves up fresh seafood.
The total bill for everything that we ate,
all of that gigantic
seafood, was THB 3,300.
Which seriously anywhere else in Thailand
that you eat that amount of seafood,
and that quality of seafood,
it's gonna be double the price.
That, really a great
value, incredibly fresh,
incredibly delicious
the way they cooked it.
That was one of the better
seafood meals of my life.
Right here in Trat, a
beautiful location, I love it.
It's like you're eating in his home.
Thanks so much for watching,
remember to subscribe
and click the little bell icon so that you
get notified of all future
videos that I publish.
Thanks again for watching,
goodbye from Trat.
I will see you on the next video.